the head coach in the New Orleans Saints
a man I'm again pleased to be able to
call a good friend he's Sean Payton back
here on the show how are you Sean I'm
doing well rich thanks for having me on
today you bet
a full look man and and I always do
start interviewing how you doing but
literally with you that is the first
thing I got to start with how are you
feeling how are you doing I'm feeling
well I'm a hundred percent I been more
than two weeks now I was cleared cleared
meaning I guess the non-contagious in
recovered okay about six days ago and
for me the experience was a the first
couple days or three days of symptoms
were chills the aches all the things
that we would normally associate with a
normal flu I didn't I had a fever on the
first day and the first day I got tested
was was when I had a fever and the
chills
the test results took a while it was
four days before I got the results back
and I'm kind of fortunate to be in that
group of that 95% group that that had it
recovered from it and now I can't get it
or can't give it and so yeah I would say
probably the last six or seven days I
felt really good went out got a chance
to get a three-mile running the other
day that's great and and I'm blessed but
we're back in into our draft meetings
they began today and obviously none of
the facilities are open for business so
we are we are at the dixie Brewing
Company in New Orleans East
and our meetings are being held here
there's a conference room our scouts are
all teleconferencing
you know skyping in there's probably
maybe five or six of us in the meeting
itself making myself Geoff Ireland in
you know we're getting up to speed with
technology and and it's going fairly
smooth so far okay so there's that
there's a little bit to unpack based on
what you just said right there coach so
first things first did the doctors who
have been administering care to you tell
you that they believe you can't give it
and get it again is that the diagnosis
you receive the understanding there's a
lot of unknown but they they're
confident that that that I can't give it
or contagious now there's a process and
I forget the word they used
generally speaking the 48 hours you know
call it four or five days three days two
days prior to you having symptoms are
your most contagious days to others it
would be too hard for me to try to guess
where I received it I spent a week in
New York I was down in Florida for a
couple days and and then back in New
Orleans and it was that Monday two weeks
ago this past Monday that I first had
symptoms they are doing some research
and I've inquired and I think they're
looking at ways to take blood from those
people that right they have you know
built up an immune system then towards
it and in whether it's through a plasma
transfer or blood transfusion so I'm
kind of waiting to hear on that to see
if if I can give blood and if it can
help but no it was for me my symptoms
were very similar to what what I would
have known is the flu I didn't have the
respiratory challenges that that so many
of the the patients or the people that
have right now and are struggling with
it okay and now to the task at hand of I
guess creating your own draft room
outside of the normal Saints facility
that has shut down because of what is
going on in the state of Louisiana which
seems to get more and more stark every
day so you have you have set up shop in
a Brewing Company in in New Orleans and
trying to IT it up to the point where
you're gonna have your own draft room
this is where from where you will
conduct the draft on April 23rd through
the 25th absolutely are our owners mr. B
when he was alive and gay
Bentsen bought Dixie brewery a few years
ago and built this brand new facility in
New Orleans e so it's it's away from
everything you you really have to would
want to have to find it and there's a
conference room in here there's a
restaurant in here it's closed
and yet the the facility relative to
what we're looking for is is fantastic
you know there's you don't see anyone
you're not around any popular populace
at all I mean the parking lots empty
you've got to drive a little bit to get
here everything's clean and new there is
a chef here that'll cater in the the
meals and today was our first day but
every team in the league right now is is
in this month going to have o to two and
a half weeks of draft meetings - we have
a board that's already staffed but
you're gonna gather the information
since the combine the workouts which
wish few there were and begin to create
your final board and so we'll operate
from here in and we're in we're in our
first day of meetings they began today
this morning Sean Payton here on the
Rich Eisen show Mickey Loomis's comments
on on Peter Kings podcasters certainly
resonating is this is it still something
that would you say you're in the
competition committee you're obviously
you're in your own situation and you're
in contact I'm sure with colleagues
throughout the NFL is this still the
prevailing thought amongst those in
management in the NFL and certainly at
the team level that this draft is is
something that should be delayed coach
well look we I know I had a chance to
listen to Mickey's and read his his
interview and yeah I guarantee you many
feel that that's the case and then
shortly thereafter it was announced that
hey that there the league is going to
have this draft at the end of the month
and from a logistics standpoint I think
we'll be able to handle you know that
the
present itself that won't be too
difficult I think the the argument and
certainly the the bigger scope of things
was just relative to everything that's
going on outside of us depending on
where you're living but it's this is
this is this is going to be a tough
tough month here for New Orleans
particularly Louisiana and and so we're
focused on the things we can control and
in that setting up a structure here and
in a meeting schedule that that's going
to be safe for our staff we have a you
know a few coaches maybe or personnel
people that have pre-existing conditions
rich they'll certainly be conferenced in
they won't be present you know and that
might be someone that has diabetes that
might be someone that has any one of
these health issues that puts them at a
greater risk we really the meeting I had
with the staff started with first and
foremost taking care of your families
and being safe all this other stuff here
really so it just kind of puts things in
perspective is you would say Sean Payton
here on the Rich Eisen show let's get to
the business of the Saints if you don't
mind you know when I heard that Drew
Brees was thinking about coming back I
had the thought you know being again I'm
not in the building just as a fan I'm
like of course he's gonna come back was
it was it more dicey than then perhaps
people thought about him coming back and
playing hi I don't know dicey wasn't the
word that was used but no but but it's a
great question because there's some what
we just assumed and we take for granted
and all of a sudden were sitting here in
14 years he's 15 years in and we've been
here quite a while and I think that each
year there's a aside from just the
physical drain there's there's an
emotional mental drain and strain
especially at that position and and also
all the things that take place relative
to your family and in your personal life
and so I think when the season ended you
know he wanted to spend time thinking
through this decision in and look to his
credits how he handles everything that
he does its well thought out
well playing in I think there was a
period where he went to the Pro Bowl and
he was back in San Diego and you know
I'd shoot him a text I didn't want to
try to convince him one way or another I
think it was best that he was around his
family and close friends to make this
decision and and you know periodically
something would come up and then I and
then I gave him this one text reason
number 27 I said the only team we have
been beaten together is the Denver
Broncos and we played them this year
that was reason number 27 right so I
think he got to a point where he felt
comfortable what he wanted to do I know
he had a handful of other options
relative to television or business and
and I think when the dust settled his
gut definitely said I want to play hmm
and then you know obviously I know you
mentioned when you were on ESPN
yesterday about do you think the Taysom
Hill and having him in the fold and you
mentioned that do you think this could
be breezes final season I mean did you
get a sense on it could be I think I
also opened up a can of worms yesterday
on Espeon because the way I said it I
think was in such a such a way where I
just he's back for his final year and
then it was like ah wait a minute you're
telling me that who is going to stop
concert touring after this season and
I'm like well I don't know if I meant it
that way I meant just like he's back and
it could be his final year right I don't
I don't know for sure I know we feel
confident and tastings ability those two
are very close we'll have a role clearly
for Taysom this season as we head into
the year we have to have another
quarterback when we decide to play
Taysom like we do in a game it's
important that that there's a third on
the sidelines so you know with what he
does he being tasted at any time he
could have a finger injury a hand injury
that would prohibit him from being a
quarterback for that game and so that
was one of the challenges last year when
drew got hurt Teddy went in to start we
kind of lost a player and a half we we
lost drew of course as a quarterback and
then now taste
truly was the to and yet we had to be
careful on how many snaps we gave him
outside of the game whether it was in
the kicking game or on offense and we
had Emmanuel Sanders on yesterday
and I told you I love that signing I
just love that guy and you're gonna pair
him with Michael Thomas and and you know
put him in that same room and Michael
Thomas to learn is if the kid is a
sponge yeah absolutely yeah the thing
that we talk a lot about when we sign a
player or we're doing right what we're
doing right now in the draft is at the
very end of an evaluation we'll say
what's the vision for this player and it
might be a backup quarterback it might
be a receiver and clearly the vision for
Emmanuel is clear you know he'll come in
he'll play Z he's someone that can play
inside in the slot if we choose the
vision is crystal clear and when you
have a clear vision for a player
generally speaking that that's a that's
a positive relative to predicting
success and I think he'll come in I've
heard nothing but great things about his
work ethic and in his attention to
detail and that was that was a good plus
for us in a little bit I don't want to
say unexpected but that first wave or
first day or so a free agency we spent a
lot of time focused on our own players
and you know down here they would say
it's a little land yet maybe well he did
say that he didn't want to go to Green
Bay because it was cold weather I think
he was kind of being serious but he also
obviously wanted to play with Drew Brees
and he said that he wanted a two-year
contract to match up with Drew and you
know in terms of running it back to
coach Malcolm Jenkins back in the fold
right there you that's that ought to be
a nice nostalgic signing but also
somebody that you know that knows your
program to bring him back in the mix
yeah you know he's he's one of those
guys that you look back and you just
hope you don't have a lot of these but
he you know he's one that got out of the
building that hindsight we wouldn't have
played it out the same way he just
there's so many things about him
that reeked of what we're looking for
he's got tremendous football makeup he's
a tremendous human being he's a great
teammate
he's extremely smart his work week is
very thorough and detailed I know the
fans in Philly and anybody around him in
Philadelphia he just he grows on you
right away he was a rookie when we
direct obviously when we won the Super
Bowl in o.9 he played nickel for us and
came in and contributed right away he's
still playing in a very high level and
he's a guy that's very versatile you
know so you see him at strong safety but
you see him down in the Box closer to
the line of scrimmage maybe more than
deeper away we're excited to have him
back before I let you go coach put your
you don't mind your competition
committee hat on and where does the
status of pass interference being
reviewable stand as we currently mankin
it's a great question we meet again
Saturday rich on a conference call in
honestly I don't know that in the last
two weeks anyone's even thought about it
it's it went from being like an
offseason priority to with everything
else that's gone on right I know there
will be some changes relative to
personnel the officiating the crew
chiefs all of that we're looking at
closely in Troy and Roger and the people
back in New York I've already begun to
to make some changes and take some steps
to move us forward I think in lieu of
what's happened you know our normal
owners meeting and competition competing
competition committee week of meetings
was really condensed into some of these
teleconference meetings now so I think
that the biggest thing that everyone
screams for is you know how do we become
more and more consistent in any phase of
officiating but how do we get more
consistent relative to what's being
overturned when it goes back to New York
and I think that is going to be really
the main focus as we meet this Saturday
and in the weeks to come and it will the
draft be on the the the subdue the
competition on us I I think you know the
powers to be and that's above our pay
grade i I think that's full speed
head right now the way I understand it
and we're preparing accordingly okay tom
brady's ginger division no if you missed
that he's now in your division is he we
exchanged a few texts got to know him
over the years here's the thing that
someone asked me yesterday you know your
thoughts about him coming to the
division and burst playing a talented
player like that the skill said he has
twice a year but I would say even more
importantly it's it's what he brings to
the program any program and in this case
Tampa Bay that's that's the thing that's
more concerning because you know the
standard or the bar or whatever term you
want to use will be elevated when you
insert a player like him as fantastic as
he is he also makes others around them
better and so that's the that's the
thing that obviously makes it a great
sign for Tampa Bay
I mean Danna be the guy to be in breezes
a year in a game where he's gonna be
facing Brady twice I mean you know
you're that that that I'm sure gets your
competitive juices going to along that
route the cannons quiet rich keep the
cannons quiet man and Bridgewater's in
the division to Sean that's amazing what
a Carolina thrill form we've
communicated a little bit and what a
great story
and another great person it just having
a chance to be around him we had one of
the better quarterback rooms that you
could ever had you know envision with
with Drew and Teddy and Kasem those guys
were outstanding together but they got
along they all have a good sense of
humor and you know they can all laugh at
themselves and I think that's an
important trait in in any industry you
know that humility if you will to make
fun of yourself and yet still be
confident but Teddy's going to have that
opportunity in Carolina and listen I'm
I'm thrilled for him and again it's kind
of that double-edged sword where you're
excited for him you just wish it was an
in another division that last one for
you if you checked on parcels how bill
was doing I asked him in fact I just I
heard you guys chatting before I got on
about the horse racing that's the one
sport that's still going right you know
he's got a few of these horses and he's
uh an avid horseman were you know he's
paying attention and the other day we
were just sitting around it was it was
Saturday was the Florida Derby was up so
this this month has always been a month
of qualifying races for the Kentucky
Derby right an important month and we
put the Florida Derby on and you can get
on a betting app and deposit money and I
hit I hit the superfecta which is the
first second third fourth place horse
and the trifecta for like sixty four
hundred dollars I had called bill I was
so excited he wanted he wanted to know
how I arrived at these horses and then
what was the bet and I got kind of gave
him the numbers and and he's like that a
boy you know he was excited so he was
he's back in Florida right now I know
he's taking care of his health good and
for anyone like Bill and there's so many
in our country our parents you know our
uncles and aunts that are all you know
shoot obviously concerned and focused on
their health because the they fall into
that group that that the numbers aren't
so good for and and so he's paying
attention to all of that we speak pretty
much weekly okay and then in the last
minute I give you the floor what do you
want people to know about the
coronavirus Shawn a look it's we're
watching it daily on TV and it seems so
simple and yet when you got in your car
and your drive but the first off I don't
know that anyone's explained flatten the
curve and what that means but the bottom
line is it's like any business if the
curve gets real steep the hospitals
can't handle all those people at the
same time so if we flatten it out all
right if we flatten it out they can
handle that amount of people over a
longer period of time and so what we're
afraid of is what's happened in New York
and what's happening here in Louie
and some of these hotspots is that the
amount the steepness of the curve can
can basically overcrowd the hospitals to
the point where hey there's not enough
equipment to care for everyone so every
one of us can be a part of this thing
the solution and it's it's it's not I
don't want to say it's simple because
obviously man it's we're stressed
financially we're stressed with
groceries we're stressed with jobs and
yet we have to stay in we have to stay
away stay safe and just recognize you
know how contagious this thing is that's
the I mean when you look at the numbers
of you know X 9 you know it's not it's
like x 10 and that's where we're at this
month is going to be a challenging month
for our country and I think we can help
flatten that curve and then spread it
out and get the hospitals certainly
those people that are working at the
front of it all the doctors nurses and
all the people involved in it man our
prayers go out to them well it's great
to hear you it's great to hear how well
you are and it's great to hear that
you're investigating to see if your
blood can be helpful to to make sure
it'll get through all this I hope you
find up some positive news on that front
and that you can you can also be a face
forward individual to get the word out
on that important aspect of this Shawn
yep you take care of yourself brother
thanks for calling Rich's always thank
you right back at you that's Sean Payton
that's a Super Bowl winning head coach
from the New Orleans Saints